bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au parlement européen à strasbourg pour
une nouvelle émission d'europe hebdo et
dans cette émission reportage direction
les pays bas focus sur un mouvement un
mouvement populiste le pvv parti pour la
liberté de geert wilders garde ville
d'or qui a fait scandale il ya peu en
demandant si ces électeurs voulaient
plus ou moins de marocains à grand
renfort de formules chocs et de
rhétorique simpliste les leaders de ces
mouvements populistes ont réussi à se
construire une façade respectable capte
l'adhésion de citoyens toujours plus
nombreux avec en ligne de mire les
élections européennes mais l'actualité
celle ukraine l'ukraine au bord de la
guerre civile c'est vladimir poutine qui
le dit l'occupation de partisans pro
russe à l'est menace le pays
d'éclatement à kiev la capitale de
l'ukraine plutôt pro européenne c'est
assez tendue vous allez le voir regardez
notre reportage
la place maiden au centre de kiev et ses
militants pro européens toujours là ici
la place de l'europe dans ce bâtiment
vit 24 heures sur 24 ces hommes
menteries ce sont des miliciens pro kiev
la situation est tendue ils sont là pour
contrer les militants pro russe qui
voudraient s'aventurer et envahir le
bâtiment clinique de la capitale notre
présence est inquiète et qui fait ce mec
là non vous inquiétez pas c'est pas en
russe c'est un journaliste français il
est là pour raconter ce qui se passe en
ukraine cela nettoie la place les restes
de la révolution qui a destitué le
président pro-russe le 22 février
dernier ici on a peur que les violences
reviennent on se rappelle encore la
soixantaine de victimes de la place
maiden des hommes des femmes tuées par
balles par les milices pro russe du
président ianoukovitch c'était il ya
deux mois lors de la révolution
elle a décidé de voir de ses propres
yeux elisabeth guigou est venu prendre
le pouls de la situation plutôt tendue
en ukraine
elle n'était pas seule la présidente de
la commission des affaires étrangères
était accompagnée de ses homologues
allemand et polonais c'est la première
fois que des parlementaires des pays
composant le triangle de weimar france
allemagne pologne se rendent ensemble en
mission dans un pays tiers
au menu une rencontre avec les grands
chefs de l'ex opposition en ukraine et
si avec l'ex champion de boxe vitali
klitschko l'un des chefs de file du
mouvement pro européens en ukraine
on est européen on est européen
géographiquement dans la mentalité avec
notre culture notre histoire on est
européen et on veut construire un mode
de vie à l'européenne
et ceux qui disent que votre mouvement
est un mouvement fasciste
c'est de la propagande c'est de la
propagande de moscou c'est faux et ce
jour là avec l'égérie de la révolution
orange ioulia timochenko elle a passé
deux ans et demi dans les geôles du
président pro russe si ianoukovitch
elle en a gardé des séquelles elle vient
d'être libérée et candidate à la
présidentielle ukrainienne du 25 mai
problème le mouvement pro européen est
divisé
klitschko et timochenko se détestent le
message de nos parlementaires est le
suivant soyez unis arrêtez d'être
divisés vous utilisé pendant la
révolution orange vous voyez à quoi cela
vous a mené un exercice de diplomatie
parlementaire ce que nous leur avons dit
c'est ce qu'il faut qu'au delà de la
compétition entre eux est normal il faut
qu'ils aient au moins un message qu
convergent sur la nécessité des réformes
ensuite et ça c'est vrai que la lutte
contre la corruption est quelque chose
qui doit absolument enfin dans ce pays
être menée dans la société civile on est
plutôt pessimiste
tania est peintre ses pensées sont
plutôt sombres elle a perdu beaucoup de
ses amis lors de la révolution il ya
deux mois
ce que je demande à tous les ukrainiens
c'est de rester unie frère même dans
cette situation difficile un ton noir du
sang le tableau que tania craint pour
son pays l'ukraine
alors nous avons été rejoints sur ce
plateau par marielle de sarnez bonjour
vous êtes eurodéputé modem dei
l'alternative voulais voir ce reportage
à ce que ça sert à quelque chose
finalement c'est cette diplomatie
parlementaire ces parlementaires
français allemands
polonais à ne pas oublier ça sert à
témoigner ça sert à recevoir un certain
nombre de messages et en passer d'autres
et dans une démocratie qui est en train
de se construire de façon fragile on le
voit bien tous les jours en ukraine je
crois que c'était important pour eux
d'avoir du soutien et et du témoignage
fait partie d'une délégation oui je suis
allé trucks je suis allé une fois au
moment la notion rangé je suis retourné
deux fois une fois au mois décembre à
une fois juste en plein moment des
événements où il ya eu de nombreux morts
sur la place de maidan j'étais là-bas
avec guy verhofstadt donc l'actualité
les chaudes aujourd'hui en ukraine
moscou l'europe accusé moscou d'être à
l'origine des heurts dans l'est du pays
est ce que vous vous êtes marielle de
sarnez favorable à des sanctions
économiques supplémentaires contre
moscou sachant que qu'elle pénaliserait
aussi les pays qui les prendraient ces
sanctions donc la france je suis
favorable à des sanctions économiques je
suis favorable à ce que l'union
européenne reste forte unie et ferme
vis-à-vis de la russie ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il faut pas dialoguer aussi il
faut trouver une issue pour la
désescalade jeudi à tout ceci n'est pas
possible il faut que vladimir poutine
comprennent une chose c'est que les
ukrainiens sont souverains et que
l'ukraine est souveraine il traîne n'est
pas un pays dans la gestion aux dépens
de la russie est donc faut qu'il accepte
cela et en même temps moi je ne
comprends pas l'intérêt de la lumière
poutine à m des chars partout à agiter
sa police militaire dans l'est a agité
les mêmes peurs en transnistrie vous
savez quand vladimir poutine soit la
douma à des prix mois la douma il ya
quelques mois de ça ou quelques années
fric on retrouve la date exacte le
permettant aux fonds aux autorités
russes d'intervenir partout soi-disant
les intérêts des minorités russophones
seraient mises en cause dans des pays en
dehors de la russie ce jour là il ya eu
effectivement un danger oui donc il faut
que l'euro cela ap reste ferme de sa
cible et députée européenne ces
sanctions elles pourraient se retourner
contre nous le rappelle dépend du gaz
russe très bien mais les russes il
dépend aussi de ce qu'on paye en échange
du gaz russe un 70 pour cent du gaz de
chez nous et 50 % des rentrées
financières pour eux et donc s'il ya pas
de gaz russe qui arrivent chez nous il
ya pas non plus de rentrées financières
pour lui donc c'est pas c'est pas si
simple que ça mais enfin on peut pas
rester sans rien faire il faut que
vladimir poutine comprennent que
l'ukraine veut avoir son propre avenir
son propre destin et que c'est aux
ukrainiens d'en décider et par exemple
il faut laisser faire les élections du
25 mai après moi je crois que l'ukraine
pourrait trouver un chemin avec une
constitution qui permettent une forme de
fédéralisme si les ukrainiens en décide
ainsi c'est pas à poutine de décider de
la future constitution ou de dessiner la
future ukraine sur la situation globale
du nain qui n'est pas d'accord avec vous
c'est le monsieur politique étrangère de
la rue s'il s'appelle sergueï lavrov
vous voulez écouter et vous réagissez
juste après
la violence amaidan qui s'est terminée
avec ce des douzaines et des douzaines
de morts était considéré comme de la
démocratie tandis que les manifestations
pacifiques qui ont lieu maintenant dans
le sud est de l'ukraine sont considérés
comme terroristes et les autorités
ukrainiennes annoncent qu'ils vont
utiliser l'armé pour mener une opération
soit disant anti terroriste l'hypocrisie
d' dépasse les bornes
alors marielle de sarnez les terroristes
des as et les combattants de la liberté
des autres ça dépend de l'âge et accepte
évidemment pas ce que vient de dire la
voix frau il est dans son rôle il est du
côté du côté de poutine dans cette
affaire mais l'agression de petits
d'abord en crimée et puis la
déstabilisation dans l'est de l'ukraine
et puis peut-être demain tant d'autres
pays proches de l'union européenne comme
la france mitri et peut-être d'autres
corps pays tout ceci l'europe ne peut
pas et ne doit pas accepter et donc
c'est un test un aussi pour l'autorité
de l'europe est-ce que quelques risques
la région suivent ce qu'elle n'y a pas
de désescalade ça continue on peut pas
laisser avancer vladimir poutine et
conquérir les territoires qui souhaitent
réconquérir et mettre à mal la
souveraineté des pays qui entourent la
russie nous ne sommes plus à une époque
d'avant il faut vadimir poutine
comprennent que le monde a changé y
compris compris en europe à tout autre
sujet marielle de sarnez vous êtes chef
de file de l'alternative modem udi en
ile de france
vous allez faire campagne sur quoi
exactement
nous sommes des européens nous sommes
clairs dans la clarté nous sommes dans
la cohérence c'est une grande différence
avec on va dire les formations plutôt
traditionnelle qui nous entourent et qui
eux ont des problèmes à régler avec
l'europe qui n'ont toujours pas réglé
qui veulent faire au fond de ce scrutin
j'ai entendu le chef de l'ump dire ce
scrutin il faut que ça soit un carton
rouge pour hollande moi je dis que ce
scrutin et doit concerner d'abord le
rock est d'abord l'avenir de l'europe
mais que me vois tous les cinq ans et
quand même pas trop que de passer un peu
de temps pour l'avenir de l'union peine
il fait ce que vous répondez à ces
eurosceptique il se retendent vers
d'autres partis populistes qui disent
que l'europe elle m'a rien apporté à moi
regarder alors à mettre des travailleurs
des h et des bulgares des roumains moi
je ne trouve pas mon boulot elle m'a
rien apporté à moi qu'est ce que vous
leur répondez leur dit que ces gens là
je leur dis que nous avons une urgence
et je pense que nous devons mettre ça
sur le calendrier des cinq années qui
viennent c'est la convergence sociale et
fiscale au sein de l'union européenne ça
y est de faire converger tous les
systèmes sociaux et fiscaux ça peut se
décider il suffit de le vouloir et on
peut le faire en cinq ans a fait partie
des propositions qui sont nos
propositions l'europe elle doit être las
pour se recentrer sur l'essentiel elle
doit être là pour apporter un plus de
croissance pour recréer à 60 pour savoir
créer la présence favoriser l'emploi il
faut qu'on se dote d'un instrument par
exemple pour permettre des
investissements pour recréer des grands
géants européens comme l'a été airbus en
son temps il faut qu'on mobilise les
pagnes européenne pour venir en soutien
des petites et moyennes entreprises
merci marica on en reparlera parce que
prononcera bien évidemment je signale à
nos téléspectateurs votre livre donc
l'urgence européenne pour plus pour une
europe plus intégrée plus efficace et
plus novatrice c'est le plus important
pour l europe se passe avec les peuples
merci marielle de sarnez et maintenant
place aux reportages il faut que je sois
parti le pvv le parti de la liberté de
geert ville des rats parti populiste
gardeur qui a fait scandale récemment en
lançant à ses électeurs vous voulez - de
marocains et bien on va s'en charger et
bien notre envoyé spécial mari la bat a
rencontré geert wilders regardez son
reportage
donc je vous le demande voulez vous pour
cette ville et pour les pays-bas plus ou
moins de marocains
donc on va régler ça
cette vidéo a fait scandale sur les
réseaux sociaux vu par des millions
d'internautes
elle montrera de l'île d'ars le leader
du pvv au soir de l'élection municipale
du 19 mars
abominable j'ai tout de suite trouvé ça
abominable du savoir vivre il est
obligatoire d'en avoir en tant que parti
politique mais ce soir là il n'y en
avait plus du tout
il tient un meeting dans un café de la
haie et ses propos jugés racistes
provoque immédiatement un tollé chez les
néerlandais qui décide par milliers de
manifester et porter plainte
collectivement contre l'homme fait très
inhabituel aux pays bas les médias eux
aussi choisi de sortir de leur réserve
c'est très rare de la part des médias et
aussi de nos propres rédacteurs en chef
qui disent ouvertement que c'est allé
trop loin ça tenait plus à la manière
dont ça s'est passé
cette façon de scander les propos ce qui
fait penser aux honnêtes gens
pour certains membres du parti d'extrême
droite c'est la phrase de trop
15 cadres décide de claquer la porte et
parmi eux le leader du pvv au parlement
européen deux députés de la seconde
chambre et éclaireurs membres du
gouvernement provincial du très costaud
on siège
pour trois ans et chaque match j'étais
ainsi à côté d'un membre du vvd
d'origine marocaine zouhair al yassini
c'était un mec comme ça déborde maroc il
m'a d'ailleurs appelé pour me féliciter
mais aussi pour m'adresser ses
condoléances
j'ai été assis à côté de lui pendant
trois ans on discutait y ont rigolé
souvent et lorsqu'il a appris ce qui
s'était passé à l'est il m'a dit alors
moi aussi il faut que je parte
c'en était trop je ne pouvais plus
rester au pvv
certes il d'un swing regrette rien
constamment entouré de ses quatre gardes
du corps l'héritier de pim fortuyn
assassiné en 2002 pour ses positions
radicales envers l'islam assume
clairement ses propos
je dis cela ce que je ne regrette pas du
tout beaucoup de citoyens et de médias
néerlandais ils ont pour la plupart
libéraux et de gauche mais on fait la
comparaison avec les événements de la
deuxième guerre mondiale ou d'autres
choses
je comprends que ça puisse faire peur
mais du coup quand ils ont compris ce
que je voulais vraiment dire quand ils
ont restitué les choses dans leur
contexte eh bien on a repris des points
dans les sondages dans les deux
dernières semaines
dans l'un des sondages même on est plus
forts qu'avant cette fameuse soirée des
élections municipales je suis très
confiant le champagne qui ont débouché
la presse et mes adversaires politiques
étaient un peu prématurée parce que nous
serons sûrement le premier parti des
pays-bas au soir de l'élection
européenne
en réalité les sondages montrent que le
pvv a bel et bien chuté dans l'opinion
onze pour cent des personnes
questionnées déclare désormais que les
chances pour qu'ils votent pour rire
builders ont diminué en raison de ses
déclarations
en quelques jours le pvv passe ainsi de
favori à second partie du pays au coude
à coude avec le parti travailliste est
celui des conservateurs mais pour
laurent chambon politologue aux pays bas
il s'agit bien d'un calcul stratégique
ce n'est pas du tout dogmatique il est
là pour gagner des voix et il est prêt à
beaucoup de choses donc il n'y a pas
longtemps c'était beaucoup
l'islamophobie ensuite c'est l'union
européenne on a eu les européens de
l'est et à limite quel que soit le thème
qui va arriver après six ans quelque
chose il va il va sauter dessus donc à
la limite si on se retrouve avec une
opinion publique néerlandaise qui
devient à nouveau pro européenne il est
capable à lui même de redevenir pro
européen pour pour en tirer des
avantages donc il faut pas sous-estimer
sa plasticité aujourd'hui la situation
s'annonce donc compliquée pour le parti
populiste dans un pays où les coalitions
sont courants je me demande un peu
quelles stratégies cherche à adopter
verte builders avant il était un peu en
réserve mais ça c'est parce qu'il
cherchait le comprenez maintenant il est
tellement extrémistes que cela peut
attirer des électeurs et le fait
remonter dans les sondages mais que
peut-il faire de tout ça puisque plus
personne ne veut travailler avec lui
fragilisé le tapage médiatique autour de
ses propos a aussi été révélateur d'une
crise interne les anciens membres du
parti parle d'une organisation quasi
dictatorial où seul réduit leader
pouvait décider de tout de quoi émettre
quelques doutes quant à l'issue des
élections européennes aux pays-bas
élection pour laquelle le pvv n'a pas
encore trouvé sa nouvelle tête de liste
alors nous avons été rejoints sur ce
plateau par bruno gollnisch bonjour vous
êtes eurodéputés front national à vos
côtés mais pas forcément du même bord
politique karim zéribi bonjour vous êtes
eurodéputés écologie les verts lors vous
venez de voir ce reportage un gars
devilder qui dit autres de marc o 4 de
marocains vous en voulez - on va s'en
charger ça vous inspire quoi ça vous
invite vous êtes da costa reportage
quand même un peu orienté vous en
conviendrez non ça me paraît quand même
assez révélateur de ce qui se passe un
petit peu en europe si vous voulez c'est
à dire que on dissèque sur le point de
savoir si telle ou telle chose a été dit
de façon élégante convenable les images
cissé c'est pourquoi la est-ce que ces
politiques ou non mais les commentaires
de vos collègues des médias est-ce que
c'est politiquement correct ce que celle
les pages que c'est un scandale est ce
que c'est un dérapage etc on ne se
préoccupe pas du tout la situation
bon le fond le fond du problème c'est
par exemple est ce que les pays baltes
sont un petit pays par l'effectif de la
population de 10 millions d'habitants
veulent continuer à recevoir une
immigration massive qui progressivement
évidemment change la donne de la
population et qui n'est pas contrôlée
voilà c'est un problème qui se pose dans
d'autres pays de l'union européenne où
la liberté de circulation qui était
prévu entre pays européens
s'effectue aujourd'hui à l'échelle
planétaire moi je respecte tout à fait
les marocains je respecte d'ailleurs
tout à fait le droit du maroc et il l'a
montré dans son histoire par exemple à
limiter la présence étrangère vu un
certain nombre de français qui se
trouvait au maroc à mon indépendance et
qui ont été priés ou qui ont été
contraints d'en d'en repartir c'est le
droit c'est le droit du maroc mais je
considère que c'est le droit des
européens aussi de limiter aujourd'hui
une immigration massive est totalement
incontrôlée mairie mais le problème
c'est une immigration massive des
marocains hollande bien sûr que nous
sommes agréés je ne crois pas que votre
sujet sont orientés je crois au
contraire qu'il pointe est véritablement
le malaise dans la manière dont certains
prétendent de faire de la politique que
l'on pose la question de l'immigration
et que l'on débatte sereinement
rationnellement de ce sujet ne me choque
aucunement et on peut parler de
l'immigration comme on peut parler de
tout autre sujet si on en parle
sérieusement
si on regarde ce que l'immigration coûte
parce que l'intégration est une
politique qui coûte mais ce qu'elle
rapporte aussi en l'occurrence son autre
sujet démontrent que là on a affaire à
quelqu'un qui est totalement xénophobe
qui est totalement raciste et qui cible
une population qui parle même pas
d'immigration qui cible une population
qui la nomme les marocains et en gros
vous les conseillez charge alors que
lorsque l'on sait qu'elle est
l'immigration aujourd'hui donc
hollandaise elle n'est pas simplement
marocaine elle vient aussi aller intra
européenne vient des pays de l'est elle
est turc elle et d'indonésie à l'origine
il ya beaucoup de surinam y est la
réalité c'est qu'il a ciblé une
population est derrière il ya beaucoup
de choses qui ne sont pas dites mais
connaissant bien marocain dit musulman
musulmans dit islam est donc là
effectivement il déroule y dérouler
déroule moi je suis plutôt rassuré de
voir que ce monsieur ne représente pas
les européens et que à hollande ils se
sont indignés dans la manière dont ils
voulaient vous prétendez vous la poser
le débat serait mise à ce que l'on
débatte et d'immigration sérieusement
l'europe vieillissante on le sait et sur
le plan de la démographie on a besoin
aussi de jeunesse on a besoin de souffle
on a besoin des larmes n'a besoin de
dynamisme et ça ne peut provenir aussi
que de l'immigration chaque grande
nation le dis chaque grand continent
l'indiquent alors après il s'agit quel
type d'immigration quel processus
d'intégration parlons-en sérieusement et
alors là effectivement je crois qu'on
peut tenir un vrai débat sur ces
questions qui sont des sujets des
questions et
ne représente pas les européens vont
regarder sûr que non le front national
veut s'allier avec le front se tiendra
le festival est le fromage aux niches si
vous voulez vous aller avec lui oui je
croque mk profond malaise on connaissait
le remercie mais reconnaissez vous
préoccuper au centre de milan de nos
alliances que vous je me sens proche de
monsieur leader sur les questions
européennes et c'est ce qui me suffit
que monsieur wylder s'exprime ce qui là
aussi les coquilles ou qu'il est mais
enfin on voit bien vous entendre phrase
une phrase prononcée valait pas grand
mal à les prononcer à l'issue
initiale des meetings dans vu dans une
municipale dans une municipale où je
suppose qui effectivement l'immigration
néerlandaises comme vous dites qui est
pas seulement marocaine c'est très vrai
qui est indonésienne qui est sur ina
mienne est donc le fond du problème
c'est que il ya une majorité aujourd'hui
enfin en tout cas un très grand nombre
de hollandais qui disent ça suffit voilà
et je pense que c'est l'endroit s'est
coincé le droit mais ces trois là qui
suivent ça veut dire nous avons essayé
de soucis ce que pensent beaucoup de
français nous avons accueilli beaucoup
de personnes d'origine étrangère
nous avons des difficultés économiques
il ya en ce moment 5 millions de
chômeurs par conséquent si l'on
construisait un bouc émissaire c'est
qu'ils n'ont de cesse que la terre et
non non si le gallois simon en ont
l'intention si nous continuons à ouvrir
nos frontières ce sera nécessairement à
des personnes qui ne seront pas en
mesure de
subvenir à leurs besoins cela cela coûte
de l'argent au contribuable français
cela coûte une fortune quoi que vous
puissiez on dirait s'adonner aux ligues
régionales on ne pas m'éloigner ici
quand ce sont des écoles comme ceux qui
travaillent
se sont quand même cela domenech dans
super des impôts mais n'ont pas encore
le droit de vote des sections locales à
ceux qui consomment qui sont quand même
en puissance donc fonctionner
leur panier je l'avais
dit que ce soit le cas joli cadeau soit
l'obligation de vous faites les
questions et les réponses on ne pourra
pas dialoguer bon allez je nie tout à
fait que ce soit le cas de l'immigration
actuelle l'émigration actuelle celle qui
vient par exemple pour sortir de la
querelle sur le marocain celle qui vient
d'europe orientale et que dire des
hommes une par exemple est bien mais
nécessairement ne peut ne peux pas
trouver les conditions d'un travail en
france alors qu'ils gagnent 5 millions
de chômeurs y ait en france
et le mali ont demandé des marocains au
départ oui on voit bien comment
effectivement le débat de ville le seul
élément même puisqu'il émulation vous
avez tout à fait résolus mais air la
cible et la pointe du doigt
je suis en droit de dire on connaît ou
très digne et ceci est notre droit
seraient introduits
le landais de trancher sur
le sujet des marocains monsieur
gollnisch je parle des roms oui c'est un
sujet qui est totalement je dirais
opposé à une demande des européens
aujourd'hui mais ce mot niches devraient
le rappeler fait des différences est né
non mais pas du tout c'est vous et
novelli parce que sans elle disait de
moi je dis que les roms ne sont pas des
immigrés mais c'est ça que je voulais
cherchons des étrangers pas croire
n'importe quoi sur mer ce sont des
étrangers qui n'entre sur notre maison
noire et donc je pense qu'ils nous avons
maintenant il y entre europe et qui
n'ont parlé d'un titre de séjour
est ce que la majorité crie de traiter
que vous avez votés ce sujet de
l'onu ce monsieur c'est le sujet général
au delà des marocains c'est est ce que
les peuples européens ont le droit de
préserver leur identité mais là il
rouvrit leur identité culturelle jean
l'identité ethnique non ma peine d re
sujet le ridant ne jurez que l'oni ch 1
meur que des européens perdent leur
identité perdre leur liaison soit envahi
mail à l'islamisation c'est un fan pas
seul c'est un fantasme de la majorité
présidentielle vous faites partie elle
est un peu responsable un peu de cette
montée du populisme en europe avec ces
histoires de travailleurs détachés ces
travailleurs ou maps
ou lundi c'est un problème effectivement
d'harmonisation sociale la question des
travailleurs détachés faire si si nous
avions les mêmes règles sociales nous
n'aurions pas de problème dans cette
histoire de la directive détachement des
salariés c'est que nous payons nous des
charges sociales et patronales qui sont
beaucoup plus élevés pour un salarié
français que ce que l'on ferait si on
prend quelqu'un des pays de l'est en
payant des charges du pays d'origine doc
c'est un vrai problème social mais ne
transférerons pas d'un problème social
qui est un problème sérieux c'est un
problème à nîmes sous conditions vous
avez beaucoup parlé de salaire minimum
romaine de fiscalité européenne qui sont
des sujets sérieux de mécanismes
effectuant une harmonisation sociale et
fiscale ne dériverons pas de ça a
effectué une politique du bouc-émissaire
de l'immigré ça effectivement c'est un
transfert qui est facile c'est une
instrumentalisation qui fonctionne et
permettez moi
ce sont des questions sérieuses lors
étendu en répandant ainsi sérieusement
se sont alarmés l'aide sociale sont des
problèmes qui sont liés car c'est un
problème qui résulte du fait que la
france entre autres comme d'autres pays
européens de l'europe occidentale n'est
plus maîtresse de ses frontières par
conséquent elle reçoit et des personnes
venues d'autres continents et des
personnes venues effectivement de pays
d'europe qui pratiquent encore le
dumping social et qui transfèrent leur
système de sécurité sociale se se
livrant ainsi à leur corps défendant
je n'accuse pas c'est malheureux
j'accuse les responsables politiques et
économiques français dont vous êtes la
différence est atteint je termine je
termine juste ce dumping social dont
sont directement victimes les ouvriers
et les travailleurs français différence
entre le second ni chez moi c'est qu'il
nous fait croire il veut faire croire
aux français qu'on pourra effectivement
ériger un nouveau des frontières ce qui
est totalement impensable et mon combat
moi c'est effectivement une europe
sociale une europe des salaires en
europe qui doit aujourd'hui comme les
terres aux sceptiques de t'en tires au
sénat
était faisable vous êtes ses repères je
suis totalement hostile à l'évolution
désastreuse de l'union européenne qui
empile aujourd'hui les réglementations
rien qu'aujourd'hui on a voté ou débattu
de soixante et un texte différent qu'ils
sont c'est un véritable poème à la
prévert nous enfilons les régulations
des les règlements les contraintes
bureaucratiques fiscale et de toute
nature cependant que nous ouvrons les
frontières sans contrôle à la
concurrence de produits qui sont
fabriqués dans des conditions
d'esclavagé par les dents dans les pays
du tiers-monde financier aux flux
financiers qui met la main sur ce qui
nous reste d'appareils productif et
effectivement au flux de personnes ce
dogme de la libre circulation des
personnes des marchandises des capitaux
a des effets désastreux si j'y pense je
suis content association de boulistes je
vais pas adhéré et payer une cotisation
les gens de bonne foi pour vous poser la
question la suivante poursuite salariés
par l'europe le député rossi l'europe si
vous êtes si cécile association de
boulistes prétend précisément décidé du
point de savoir qui vous devez recevoir
chez vous à quelle heure vous devez
sortir prélever une cotisation alors que
vous n'êtes pas intéressé par jouer
bull effectivement vous allez vous
intéressé de très près à l' association
de boulistes c'est très exactement ce
que nous faisons parce qu'il faut
bloquer cette machine qui est demeurée
bonne machine et sans slogan à la
différence qu'ils montraient rapidement
tomber ce goni chez moi il est anti
européen il veut effectuer mettre fin à
leur paie ça n'est pas possible et moi
je veux changer l'europe je veux
réorienter l'europe je veux une re plus
juste nom de la solidarité et de
l'harmonisation sociale je crois que le
premier sujet de la mandature oui mis
d'accord en tout cas vous réalisez un
combat pour une europe sociale merci
messieurs merci d'avoir accepté notre
avis merci ça fait
très attention c'est la fin de roberto
restez avec nous sur les chaînes
parlementaires